in recent years Brazil has gone through
a rollercoaster of turmoil between
economic woes corruption scandals and
impeachment proceedings Brazil is in a
deep crisis many blaming fingers point
to President Dilma Rousseff who is
recently suspended from office but this
has been a slow unraveling for the
world's fifth most populous country so
here's the situation in order to
understand Rousseff you need to start
with her predecessor President Luiz
inácio Lula da Silva aka Lula
rags-to-riches story
Lula was wildly popular and became a
symbol for Brazil's economic extent as
one of the top exporters in the world of
commodities such as oil soy beans corn
and iron ore Dilma Rousseff was Lula's
protege and became the first woman to be
elected president of Brazil in 2010
during Rousseff's presidency global
prices for raw materials began dropping
and a corruption scandal paralysed many
infrastructure projects putting severe
strain on Brazil's economy how bad did
it get Brazil's economy shrank 3.8
percent in 2015 the most in a quarter
century the country's credit rating was
downgraded to junk and business and
consumer confidence levels fell to
nearly their lowest on record
Rousseff's presidency has also been
strained by the massive scandal
involving Petrobras the state-run oil
company an investigation dubbed
Operation car wash revealed a deeply
corrupt organization and government it
unearthed to scheme started over a
decade ago involving bribery collusion
and kickbacks implicating Petrobras
executives and Brazilian officials
Rousseff herself has not been named in
the probe what might prove Rousseff son
doing however are claims she doctored
accounts to cover up the government's
deficit woes during her 2014 re-election
campaign in March more than three
million Brazilians took to the streets
calling for Rousseff's ouster on May
12th the Senate voted to put her on
trial if found guilty she would be
removed from office permanently
however Rousseff denies any wrong
now here is the argument those in the
anti Rousseff camp say that her time is
over
even if she survives her upcoming trial
which many say she won't a fragmented
government an angry public will prevent
her from accomplishing anything
meaningful the pro Rousseff camp say
Rousseff successor vice president Michel
temer isn't much better just last year
he tweeted quote impeachment is
unthinkable
since then Rousseff herself has accused
him of attempting a coup looking big
picture there aren't many good guys here
352 of Brazil's 594 members of Congress
are currently under investigation for
corruption charges brazil's future is
uncertain right now but whoever rises to
power next faces a tough task and
stitching the country back together